um let's get into um some money advice
for the for the
regular
joe's and sally's out there who are like
all right richard i get it buy the dip
buy the dip but your best piece of
advice so i'm just checking to see if
i'm gonna miss my next interview um i uh
my original books i'm a serial
entrepreneur um crypto used to not exist
i was rich and retired before crypto was
invented so my original books are on how
to hire how to dress how to market how
to have a unique selling proposition how
to use referrals you know how do you
find someone that not only can do the
job but will do the job like normal
bread and butter bad ass
entrepreneurship is in my books crypt is
not so if you go to t dot me slash live
or go on youtube and listen to the
audiobook s-c-i-v-i-v-e
ain't no crypto in there but the thing
is crypto broke all that advice crypto
now murders any of those businesses oh
you work real hard in your business you
pay 35 percent of your tax congrats oh
you work crypto 20
what do you want to pay 35 percent tax
or 20 uh twenty's better we're saying
capital gains versus ordinary income
yeah if you work hard in your business
you're paying 35 period that's it
there's no way around it like i mean
there ain't no way around it like they
work hard to make they make it very hard
for you to get out of that yeah well the
the they just hired another 87 000 irs
agent so
so stupid dude goods and services are
all that matter those are agents are not
producing goods or services they're
harming the people that do
i'm not a fan yeah i understand you on
that one um so when you were growing up
someone must have pulled you aside you
must have heard something where someone
was like
hey buddy you got to remember
what was the best piece of advice that
you received so i was told that
salespeople made the most money and then
like when i used to do air conditioning
i used to fix air conditioners for a
living
and i would go to people's houses like
stock brokers make money doctors lawyers
make money you want to be a lawyer seven
year school take on debt you want to be
a doctor seven year school take on debt
don't make nothing when you get out
you're a lawyer when you graduate you're
like making cold calls trying to do
wills for old ladies you suck you can't
do anything they didn't teach you
anything useful in school by the way you
guys do want to be lawyers go become a
lawyer in louisiana
you can do it without taking school you
can just take the bar exam straight in
louisiana get your license there without
having to go to school and then export
it to other states
so you can become a part of the system
right now yeah you can become a lawyer
that's just what we need in this country
more lawyers who don't know the laws
that's the great part is they all go
into politics so double bad like
lobbyists so bad like just no like the
majority of the political class in the
united states is lawyers so what do they
do they make a lot of verbose bad stuff
mostly and they think they know how to
do business but they don't
i'm a big advocate of um so learn sales
go into sales
and go into business or better yet go to
crypto but if you can't do crypto
business is second best
as far as return on your investment yeah
i mean the second best return that you
can get to crypto is startups
so like you know peter thiel did pretty
good with facebook yeah like
startups are the best roi that you can
do next to crypto
it's not easy though no it's not
you can lose most businesses fail like
eighty percent yeah especially everyone
started a restaurant that's the most
likely to fill business yes it's
probably like 95 percent so if you like
that clip click right here to watch
another or if you want to watch the
entire sauce cast click right here